- You're the raddest looking human ever.
Like, we--
(audience cheers)
Like things I dream of in my head,
I'm like, I could try this,
you pull off all of them.
- I just don't want to feel
like I look in the mirror
and I look conservative and straight.
I don't know, somebody like--
(laughs)
You know, like, you know,
sometimes I pass Brooks
Brothers and I think to myself,
"well that ain't bad," and
I'm like, "what do you mean,
that's bad."
- I love, here's the thing,
I love Brooks Brothers.
- Yeah, me too. But, you
know, like really being in
like a pinstripe suit
with my real color hair,
which I haven't seen since I was nine.
- I was gonna say, I don't
think you're ever going
to be able to fight rock and roll.
I think that's just gonna
naturally exude from you.
That's what we love about you.
Have y'all ever met before?
- Yeah.
- We have.
- You know, on her show.
- On my show. But I agree with you.
As soon as I look too proper,
I'm like uh-uh. You know?
- Like, you know, I don't know
what older artists look like.
- Kinda like this.
(audience laughs)
- Nah, you look beautiful. You're not old.
In what age, time, realm
do you think you are in?
- I'm gonna be Basic
Betty, though, even at 70.
It's gonna like, when
I grow up, I'm gonna,
I'm cool with it. That's who I am.
I'm like rollin' with this, Cindy.
(audience cheering)
- What I always think of is your song
"What Doesn't Kill You --
- You know that song?
(audience laughing)
- [Cindy] I do.
- I'm so cool right now.
- I used to like, whenever
I was feeling really
kind of like, downtrodden, I
would like sing along with it.
- I love that you even heard it.
- Are you kidding it was a huge hit.
- Oh my God, well thank you!
(audience cheers)
All right so tell us about
your, its home for the
holidays right?
- We're coming to LA
usually we're in New York,
but this year, its a special year.
We're coming to LA. LA.
- LA. I like how you say it.
(audience cheers)
- It's our big fundraiser
this year, um well every year.
It's the main thing we do
for the true colors united,
it's an organization that we
did to help eradicate I guess,
youth homelessness.
And that ranges anywhere
from 12 to 24, and what we
discovered is that there's
3.7 million kids on the
street in one year.
And up to 49% of them were
LGBTQ, which is lesbian or gay.
And you start to realize
that a lot of these kids
are getting thrown out of
their homes as they come out
to their parents.
I'm a mom,
you never get the kid,
the kid that's who you want the kid to be,
the kid is who the kid is.
And as a mom,
(audience Cheering)
you don't wanna throw you kid out.
- It's great that you do
that work and I think its so,
people think it's better, and
it is, but it's not better
everywhere, and it's not
better in every household.
- It's not better
- Well when better comes from
the bar that's way down here
then you've still only made it here.
You've gotta have a long way to go.
- But guys, its not.
I mean we've been trying,
but it's still up to 40%.
I just think that we can
do stuff with education
and different programs, which
we have been involved with.
We bring a lot of organizations
together and outreach
programs together. This is the work we do.
We lobby, we've had people
from like 50 cent, to Pink,
to Laverne Cox.
- I think what's most important
to point out, I know you're
not gonna say this, but
just the fact that you are
unique and you are an original,
and a lot of the kids you
are speaking to are unique and
original and they stand out
in their community.
The fact that you're leading
it up means all the world.
(audience clapping)
like it's not somebody
shouting from the rooftop
that doesn't get it. That's the key.
You took your platform
though, and you did something.
That's a cool thing.
- You can't throw away or
youth. Our youth is our future.
We're parents, we stand by the kids.
We have to, because honestly
you won't have a future
if you don't listen to them.
(audience clapping)
come to the show December 10th.
- Okay so where is this concert happening?
- At the noveu theater on December 10th.
October 18th tickets
go on sale, and that's
truecolorsunited.org and
get all the information
get information about what
we do, and together we can
actually change the situation.
And once we take care of
that 40% we can move on to
the rest.
- The volunteer.